[Music]
close your
eyes and you will find
[Music]
yourself when I was a
boy my mother used to tell me a
story of a demon king and his
army they brought fire and Terror to the
land
until they face the protector of the
people the white
monkey there you
are you are a
beast in this city the rich don't see us
as
people give me the job no one wants to
do I'll do
it anyone who forgets their place it
doesn't turn out well for
[Music]
them this is not the place to work if
you can't handle that sort of
stuff every
day I've prayed for a way to protect the
weak I've got an answer to every prayer
I call her
Nikki Minaj big bumper nice headlight
let's boo
[Music]
it we
got
MC 1 2 1 2
[Music]
3 need to fight for your mother for all
of
us anger will not Qui to Soul my
son don't call me
[Music]
son it's time to
remember but
only
just one small
Ember can burn down
everything ladies and
gentlemen are you ready for a [__]
fight 1 2
[Music]
yeah